صباح الخير لك يا ندى، فما هي
أهمية اجتماع يوم الاثنين في كييف
خاصة بالنظر إلى عدم اليقين بشأن
التمويل الأمريكي المستمر لأوكرانيا،
حسنًا، يبدو رائعًا، أعني أن هذا
مهم للغاية من حيث الرمزية
هنا خاصة في أعقاب ذلك
القرار الذي اتخذته الولايات المتحدة.  استمعنا إلى الكونجرس الأمريكي
بالأمس من وزير خارجية الاتحاد الأوروبي
جوزيف بوريل وهو يتحدث
إلى جانب وزير الخارجية الأوكراني
واصفًا ذلك بأنه تعبير واضح عن
إرادة والتزام
الدول الأعضاء في الاتحاد الأوروبي بمواصلة
دعم أوكرانيا حتى في مواجهة
الدعم النحيب من
البعض.  أعضاء الكونجرس الأمريكي ديمتري
وزير الخارجية الأوكراني
يرددون أيضًا هذا الشعور حيث تحدث
عن أهمية هذا الاجتماع
لوزراء الخارجية الذي
ربما بكلماته ليس في حدود الاتحاد الأوروبي
في هذا الوقت ولكن في حدود الاتحاد الأوروبي المستقبلية
بالطبع لا تزال أوكرانيا  المضي
قدمًا على أمل أن يتم
منحهم عضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي، وقد
سمعنا بالأمس أيضًا من
ممثلين آخرين للاتحاد الأوروبي
ووزراء خارجية آخرين يشاركون في
مجلس الشؤون الخارجية هذا، ولم تكن
جلسة رسمية من الناحية الفنية
لمجلس الشؤون الخارجية نظرًا لأنه  لقد
حدث ذلك خارج نطاق سيادة الاتحاد الأوروبي، لذلك لم يتم التوصل إلى
استنتاجات رسمية أو
اتفاقيات ملموسة ولكننا رأينا بعض
المؤشرات الإيجابية خاصة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بآمال أوكرانيا في الانضمام إلى
الاتحاد الأوروبي والاستماع إلى هذا
البيان من وزير الخارجية الألماني الذي
تحدث أمس
مع مجلس الخارجية هذا.  من وزراء خارجية الاتحاد الأوروبي،
نحن نأخذ
الاتحاد الأوروبي نحو قلب أوروبا، وهو
أقوى نبض في الوقت الحالي هنا في كييف
هنا في أوكرانيا، مستقبل أوكرانيا يكمن في
الاتحاد الأوروبي في مجتمع
الحرية لدينا، وسوف يمتد قريبا من
لشبونة إلى لوهانسك مع كل قرية
مع كل متر تحرره أوكرانيا
ومع كل متر تنقذ فيه
شعبها، فإنها تمهد طريقها أيضًا إلى
الاتحاد الأوروبي
الآن بالإضافة إلى مقترحات
التمويل المستمر والجديد لأوكرانيا
من الاتحاد الأوروبي في الاتحاد الأوروبي كما تحدث
جوزيف بوريل رئيس الشؤون الخارجية في الاتحاد الأوروبي.
هذا الالتزام، قائلاً إن
هذا كان إلى حد ما فيما يتعلق بعضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي،
وقد يكون أكبر
التزام يمكن أن تقدمه هذه الدول الأعضاء
لأوكرانيا في هذا
الوقت الحالي، وفي الوقت نفسه
قال وزير الخارجية الأوكراني
إنهم يعتقدون أن هذا يسير في
الاتجاه الصحيح من وجهة نظرهم.  إن الحكومة الأوكرانية
وزعماء الاتحاد الأوروبي على نفس الصفحة عندما
يتعلق الأمر باحتمال عضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي، فمن وجهة
نظره، من المحتمل أن تتم المفاوضات قبل
البداية قبل بداية
العام المقبل، وهذا بالتأكيد
مؤشر إيجابي من الاتحاد الأوروبي ولكن
بالطبع هناك
متطلبات صارمة مفروضة على أي دولة
تسعى للحصول على عضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي،
ولن تكون أوكرانيا استثناءً من ذلك، ونحن نعلم
أن الاتحاد الأوروبي قد قدم
سبع توصيات على الأقل للإصلاحات التي يتعين
القيام بها في أوكرانيا، بما في ذلك مكافحة
الفساد وغسل الأموال
وحرية الصحافة.  وحقوق الأقليات، لذلك لا يزال هناك
بالتأكيد الكثير للعمل عليه
ولكن من الواضح أنها رسالة التزام،
رسالة دعم متجدد من الاتحاد الأوروبي
لأوكرانيا